hey I'm Liza Koshi and today I'm doing
the wired autocomplete interview yes I
have googled myself before I just about
every day in the morning that's how I
wake up it's my morning routine I'll
know every answer
thank you does Liza Coe she does Liza
Koshi have siblings I do my mom made
three brown girls and she's a white
woman herself it's pretty exciting
she made me my sister Olivia and my
other sister
Rahil which is a very Indian name I am
the youngest so my parents kept trying
until they had the best and just had to
stop
does Liza Koshi talk to herself do we
talk to herself yes we do all the time
she's great you can't help it I just
have to keep talking time because I love
her and she's pretty what what was the
question how does Liza Co she'd dance
like this I'm sorry I hit the mic I'm so
sorry about that
like this I'm not wearing a mic pack
what this is how my body moves this is
how I dance thank you for watching how
does Liza Co she do her eyebrows um I I
use a lot of materials and actually a
protractor no I I actually use a benefit
browsing there's a plug you can send me
so maybe like I've used Sharpie before
its I've actually had somebody wipe a
part of my eyebrow off before and I
filled it back in with a blue pen
there's nothing that cuz there's another
board give it to me sorry is Liza Koshi
married to herself into the money no I'm
just kidding I am single next question
oops is Liza Koshi vegan no I love
sausage like in the appropriate way no
but I love me I'm from Texas and I love
marinated vaginas fajitas is Liza Co she
rich in love and happiness and
friendships and money
Wow in in in friendships yes money
next video is Liza ko she's best friend
I like to preach nowadays to be your own
best friend but that just sounds lonely
because I am No my best friend is myself
also david dobrik and also my sisters
and my mom just keep them coming
please don't you sorry did Liza ko she
go to college I went to school for one
year
I majored in nothing because I went for
one year it was amazing I don't remember
it said Liza ko she get a dog no I
didn't I want a dog I really am craving
some kind of furry companion in my life
okay if I were to get a dog I would get
a dachshund mixed with a what's it
called cocker spaniel oh yeah that's a
dachshund mix with a cocker spaniel it's
a dog I have at home in Houston and it's
brilliant it's in the shape of a wiener
love sausage remember cool callback did
Liza Koshi get tattoos yes I actually
own a tattoo on my nose can you zoom in
can you see that that little like - on
my nose my friend was getting a tattoo
and I wanted to send a picture to my mom
and pretend that I was getting a tattoo
on my face and the tattoo artist
accidentally moved and niched my nose do
you see that little black mark cool that
was a complete lie I don't have any
tattoos next question where did Liza
Koshi grow up
Houston Texas baby might have this hair
is not mine so I'm surprised that didn't
fall out baby I'm so sorry
what is Liza ko she's real name my real
name is Elizabeth Koshi I'm a
pathological liar and I go by Liza what
does Liza co she want I want happiness
for myself and for other people that was
cheesy but true
what does Liza Koshi like to do rip
these tiny pieces of paper off I love
creating and I love sleeping both happen
at the same time what does Liza Koshi
watch on YouTube herself she is a big
fan of little brown girls no I actually
I love watching ASMR videos
it's those videos that have
on it that like this kind of sound like
to fall asleep spare sense that's why
this sound is so pleasing what languages
does Liza Koshi speak English es peor
hola I don't speak Spanish it's a lot of
fun and I also love tacos but I'm not
Hispanic do we have another card
how is Liza Co she pronounced Lisa
Kudrow how tall is Liza Koshi
I am 5 feet tall today I'm five six
what's up how did Liza Koshi become
famous yeah I honestly don't know you
guys have weird tastes online how does
Liza Koshi invent characters they're all
part of me and they're my split
personalities that I actually have in my
brain so they all come from different
parts of my brain yeah that was hard to
explain I'm fine what next time next
board how jet how does jet pack skinsky
sleep wait sorry
he doesn't close his eyes I'm apologize
okay we're good how does jetpack skinsky
make his money he spends a lot of time
with hope of women and they pay for his
dinners
honestly just by being good-looking and
modeling for GQ hopefully wouldn't it
what does jetpack skinsky eat I can let
say it on camera but corn
how does jetpack skinsky have a good
time every time is a good time with Jed
he's just a happy man I mean when you're
that good-looking it's hard not to be
happy you know last one Haga liza co
she-goat what what are you typing it to
Google are you saying how the Liza Co
she is the greatest of all time are you
saying go like that hope you found that
video you were looking for love goats
big fan bad bad is Helga Liza Co she's
cousin Helga is Liza coffee Skelton she
loves her very much very proud to be
related blood sisters here we go next
question where is Helga from she is from
a place I actually don't know I actually
have no idea where I'll get she's from a
beautiful place called
my brain nice smooth I actually have no
idea where she's from though sorry